Okay,
should be live here.
Check my sound settings. Yeah, we're
good.
Let me set the title
or rather the uh the category
not
net hack
software and gamedev. Cool.
Okay,
let me show you where we're at at the
moment.
And this is the breakout solve.
Cleaned up the dashboard.
Gave it a little new coat of paint.
Super fast.
Let us
I think I liked having this here more.
Yeah, this is good.
I'm trying to see if I think that this
is fine.
I think we were just using it for the
inputs.
Okay,
this is gross.
Precision
Well, I'm doing the coarse grain edits
first, so I'm just going through and um
leaving a bunch of comments on obvious
crap.
Then we'll get this auto refactored or
semmanual semi-auto refactor
and we'll go from there.
These can probably get cleaned up.
They're okay for now.
probably early Septemberish, like two
months.
End of summer, whenever I decide end of
summer is.
Yeah, we just we have a lot of bloat
with needing two different precisions.
Yeah, having this included way down here
is shitty.
Are you what?
I'm working on just refactoring
messy crap in um 50. Trying to get the
code into roughly reasonable shape.
I figured I'd give it a quick try.
Elliot said that it's faster. So, we'll
see if it's giga stupid. And if not, I
mean, the main thing is I just need
these things to be faster, right?
for you. I would definitely suggest
worrying less about models and more
about fundamentals.
This is my code. This is Well, actually,
hang on. Did it bloat this a little bit?
It'll have to be for fine grain.
It just slips all sorts of [ __ ] in
here.
Just don't fall into the mental trap of,
"Oh, I don't need to learn things
anymore." It's a very dumb one.
Did we not figure this out at compile
time?
I think we'll leave this one alone.
It'll make more of a mess.
is we're only 25% of the way through
this file.
The good news is a good like large
chunks of this file are going to be
totally fine.
Okay. So, the good news here, right,
all of this stuff here
is from 40.
So, minus a couple weird bits.
Most of this will be fine
until we get to here.
Checkpoint and logic definitely will use
work.
This is big colonel. But this is from
before.
It uses too many function boundaries on
a crap though.
Yeah, good chunks of this still need to
be audited, but good chunks of it are
fine. I think probably
at least half of this is just from
Huffer 4 and it's fine.
And then there's a chunk of this that's
like either
LM crappy port or just not merged well
or whatever.
Weight bank and frozen stuff is all
selfplay.
Uh it's mostly just refactoring the
implementation. I got the structure of
it good. It's just that it's the code
for that is bad.
Wait long.
Yeah, very very long.
Look at that.
Well, I mean this is what we have to
clean up, right?
I we need to cut at least 1,000 lines
off of this file.
This is all sweep stuff.
Okay.
Oh, we have our work cut out for us.
insanely large codebase. Not really,
man.
Take a look. Oops.
for all of RL infra algorithms,
the whole visualization with
constellation, our soda hyperparam
tuning algorithm, our tensor processing
library, like everything is here.
Yeah, Jess.
It's not so much a prompt. Like, I just
went through and tagged a bunch of
stuff. If I just do
like
this is just all a whole bunch of tags
from me.
Hang on.
It's good that this thing is actually
fast. This is actually This feels a lot
less shitty. I will say having to sit
here and wait for like 1 minute for a
substantial thing. This actually like
puts me thinking most of the day rather
than just like eyes glaze over being
idiot.
Uh h how long have I been trying it?
About 15 minutes.
This is really jank.
Actually, this is awfully jank.
Ton of feedback.
This feels less [ __ ] because I'm not
just sitting here waiting for most of
the time.
I will say that this is at least a
significantly better interface than um
flawed or codeex.
This seems to have
it's kind of funny like
it's really shitty design to have the
models cranked such that um you have to
sit there waiting for 10 minutes or
whatever.
I mean, in some sense, the longer it
takes the model to return on feedback,
the more you just turn it into vibecoded
horseshit where like you're not actually
expecting the person to do anything.
Faster model definitely better.
Hey Elliot, so far it's definitely
faster and uh I definitely value that.
I mean, this is taking
this is taking maybe a few minutes, but
like I gave it a ton of stuff. I
basically sat there for 10 minutes
writing um you know maybe 20 different
changes down.
Mhm.
That's better.
Okay, this is taking a while, but I this
is a lot of changes to be fair.
This is
okay. Not amazing.
New dashboard is nice. Looks clean.
Thank you.
I think Track Mania is already like a
record already broken by AI or whatever,
right? You could, but you'd have to
reimplement the whole damn
CTO data from constellation.
You can. It's a little tricky, but yes,
you can
Okay, this is the same length as before,
but actually we have cut code because um
it's the same length as before. A couple
maybe a little bit shorter having
deulfed a bunch of stuff. You know,
there was a ton of stuff line that
should not have been onelined.
We can kind of just keep taking passes
over this file until it's good.
Dude, what are you doing with this
optimizer?
You have like a 2K parameter policy.
I got 1.6 six with the original network
using um it's like 30 some odd million
steps per second using async and GPU.
Also, if you tried this on um
you have like 2048 stuff
like we try breakout for infrastructure
and quick verification but it's not um
results on breakout are not always
transferable.
It's a pretty simple N.
You don't really need to learn Rayb.
That's kind of the cool thing. You just
start using it immediately.
See, the thing is it shouldn't you
shouldn't really need to move it to
CUDA.
You only get bottlenecked um
by CUDA above like 10 m
leveled out. Yeah. So that's going to be
your params, dude.
Like RL does not infinitely scale down
in params. You do need some
I could see getting it in like 1.3 mil
or whatever if that's what you mean like
1 milish.
Note that like our sweeps can actually
find more compressed model size if you
change the settings, but that's not what
they're optimized for. They're optimized
at the moment for um wall clock solve
time. It's a different objective
versus compression.
That changed. It's not going to change
anything though, is it?
lower pram count and beats a higher one.
It should run.
Yeah, but like if if you find a smaller
model, right, that needs 10 times the
amount of data, it can still end up
being slower.
You can end up with like so there's a
parto curve between all these different
things, right? There's a data versus
compute parto curve for instance. Um
there's a compute and model size curve
and you're generally looking for the
favorable portions of that for the thing
you care about which is usually just the
solve time.
We got a ton kind of different types we
have to care about annoyingly here.
I remember I spent some time looking
into this though and there's not a great
way to do this.
What am I working on? Refactoring uh the
new pure CUDA back end or not even back
end. Barracuda NC
I don't know if I like this to be
honest.
What the heck?
Oh,
Pick pointing is also pretty bloated.
Good.
I didn't actually get much out of trying
to do BF-16 OBS,
There's quite a lot of code to go
through
actually. How many uh what do we have in
one page of code?
Five. Yeah. So, it's just over like a
100 pages of code.
Okay, that's fine. I see why it does
this. That's chill.
the data is FP32
initially. Everything always gets cast
into BF-16
for the mat moles Oh,
Uh, it's dumb, Jess. But at least it's
not dumb after making me wait 10 minutes
and like lose all interest.
Yeah, that's brand new, man. We've got
um we got breakout to 1.6 second solve
on it. Uh the async stuff is considered
experimental.
It does slightly degrade signal in
return for higher throughput. So, we
need to rerun sweeps.
GPU support was just easy, so we added
it for the hell of it.
We're going to need it eventually.
Okay, we have a lot of um keyword
[ __ ]
it shouldn't. If it does, that's a bug.
It would make it slightly more off
policy than before. Also, that reset
state thing is also from like two days
ago. I separately tested that that
actually works now. It didn't work
before. There was a a problem with it.
Oh, hang on. I lost my train of thought.
I was Dang it. What was I think Oh,
right.
We don't really care about con
correctness.
Double buffered.
It's not double buffered though, Lance.
Acync double buffered roll up B.
So the starting state is going to be
stale in the same way
uh in the same way your whole update is
stale, right?
Yeah,
I have to look at that. I don't think
that there's I don't think that'll break
that option. It's just more off policy,
which is what you expect from async
anyways.
I'm just refactoring 5C a bit.
It's the code is too long.
There's just too much crap.
So essentially what happened here right
is
LLM heavy port of the Python sections to
C and CUDA me refactoring the project
structure heavily until I got it into
the right shape and now we just have to
go through and do the like function by
function and then ultimately line by
line
improvements.
Five.
Um, I've been trying this. I was using
codeex before. It's just very slow.
Um, I've just been using this today and
it's much faster at the very least.
Generally, like the amount of suffering
and just awful I feel at the end of the
day is directly proportional to the
amount of time between me getting to do
stuff when it's basically me type
something every 10 to 15 minutes into
stupid language model. I just like work
is just awful and nothing gets done and
like two or three days of that and I'm
basically just like no longer even
motivated to show up to work here.
So it's more so a practical
like
practical decision than anything. I
don't really care
if the model is slightly smarter if it
gets it wrong anyways
and just like quadruples the amount of
time I have to wait for it to be wrong.
Like none of these models are good
enough to just make the code good.
Yeah, but I don't want to be swapping
around, man. Like,
that just decreases the amount of
control I have over each of those
individual things.
There are a few small things I could do
stuff like that on, but um
you know, broadly I don't just want
these things adding tons of crap code.
It takes much much less time for these
things to come up with a way to add a
ton of crap code than it takes me to
like go through and actually fix the
damn repo.
You know, basically takes one day for
them to just screw up all the code and
uh then it takes me two weeks to fix it.
And let me tell you, it is not fun
fixing it at all.
It's just like brutal and exhausting.
And typically I need a vacation by the
end which is
I mean that's just not ideal.
Ideally we keep the research in a way
that's
reasonable workflow where I can just
keep cranking on it for longer.
Um, also I will say that like I'm pretty
sure that still not once has the uh any
of the models come up with a useful
genuinely useful idea in Puffer like
ever.
like all the core improvements and stuff
have just been from myself or in a
couple cases from some of the
contributors thinking about problems.
That goes for the core infra,
that goes for the algorithm, that goes
for pretty much everything.
These models are useful, but they are
definitely not smart.
Like running sweeps is
what's this?
Running sweeps is useful, but um we kind
of have soda sweeps.
I mean it also depends but like what you
mean by like oh it came up with like
look what it came up with like does it
count with it should not count as it
coming up with a good idea if I say test
A B CDE E and it goes through and it
says a yeah D is the best Hey,
Yeah, but like
it only does so through a very very
local process.
Like for instance, I never trust
negative results like ever from these
models. If I try if I have a the model
try out an idea and it says this doesn't
work like you can never trust the
negative results
cuz often times it just does it wrong.
Workaholic. Yeah, exactly.
But the thing is like
know I have multiple people now who work
quite a bit and are
much much smarter than this model
and they have the benefit of using the
models.
There's not going to be an intuition
update.
Uh, I will not be using any of the
anthropic models out of principle. Thank
you.
I'm sick of giving them I said like even
months before they did all this crazy
stuff lately, I was sick of giving them
money. And lo and behold,
What did anthrop um I mean basing
basically poisoning the world ide
ideologically against AI in like a
batshit insane way that makes absolutely
no sense
and
trying to get like major major sanctions
imposed on AI that make absolutely no
[ __ ] sense.
Stop.
Is it still?
No, it's it's still going.
See, this is easy, though. This isn't
just like having to figure like bisect
and figure out which of these const
keywords actually matters.
Well, we dropped some keywords and we
didn't regress the PF of the library.
So, that's nice.
How is roll out a guaranteed
the train?
Okay, so Lance, the way that
you might be thinking about it wrong. So
the way that um the buffering works,
it's not like the puffer two or puffer
maybe three. It's not like the double
buffering thing where you're swapping in
like different chunks or whatever. You
just have all of the M's in a block and
you can asynchronously like do whichever
block of M's is ready. But the async new
thing in 5C, that's a different async
thing. So what that specifically does is
the clean bus style async where you do
the first um you do your first set of
rollouts, right? And then you optimize
the policy from that set of rollouts
while keeping a copy of that original
policy frozen and used on continuing
from that set of rollouts.
And then that batch of data goes to the
trainer which is now if you'll look at
it exactly one epoch stale. And from
there on what ends up happening is all
of your training data is precisely one
epoch stale.
So the result of that should be that
your hidden states are also one epoch
stale.
So yes there's drift but there's drift
in the exact same way that the weights
are also now one epoch stale.
Why is that a good thing? Because it
lets you run training inference at the
same time. You get about plus 10 million
SPS on breakout from that alone.
If your ENV is slow, it also lets you
just like crank on training while you're
running the EN.
It's basically
it's like the Impala architecture, but
it's the clean variant where you're
never like multiple data epochs behind.
You have it controlled to one.
Mind you, you can crank on that as much
as you want, right? You can crank on the
data a lot if you want, but you're only
one step. Is it stable comparably? How
many%? So, that's what we're still
testing, which is why is it
experimental? Uh, when you re- sweep it,
you get soda on breakout.
for any fixed set of well let's put it
this way for most fixed set of
hyperparameters that I've tried you see
a bit of degradation
uh when you go to one epoch stale versus
zero.
So it essentially comes down to uh you
know a perf versus sample quality thing
and we're going to be testing it on the
more uh indicative harder ends right
now we do have vrace
but the thing is we've had vrace before
right if you read our blog post the
puffer advantage function we have is uh
it's the one one of the few very like
mathy things that I've managed to do was
uh the puffer for advantage function
strictly generalizes both J and V trace.
The vrace alone is crap, but vrace with
J works nicely.
It would be very good at starting
trainer.
Wait, what do you mean
of epochs?
No, it's not like it's not like Impala
where it just keeps cranking the
processes forever.
So you still can set a fixed number of
updates.
So it actually maintains determinism in
that sense. Um you can still have a
fixed number of updates
on the training data. It's just that
those updates happen at the same time
using a version of the policy that is
exactly one epoch stale.
So it's much more controlled and
reproducible than something like Impala.
We might be able to have one path and
just change the compute types.
Wait, hang on.
I understand roll out is n plus1 is
associated with states.
reset equals false
is the recurrent state at the beginning
of each ready roll out stored
as part of that rolling block.
It's supposed to be yes
the recurrent state at the beginning of
each ready roll out.
Yes, that's how it's supposed to work.
So at the start of each I mean you break
the uh since it's two it's one it's two
epochs like async it swaps back and
forthish
it's you store the recurrent state at
the start of each
roll out. Yeah.
And it gets swapped into the training
buffer. It's supposed to cuz it's the
initial state that you need, not the
final one, right?
Wait,
non-geem Mark.
percent compared with zero lag. Yeah.
So, if you look at the original Cleanba
paper, Costa has a lot of good stuff on
that, but like RL as a whole has evolved
a lot since then, especially with the
stuff in Puffer. So, that's the type of
thing we're going to have to measure.
It's tough because like the hypers shift
for sync versus async, you know. So, we
have to do some pretty aggressive
sweeps, which is why this is considered
a a beta feature in 5C at the moment. I
put it there though so we can optimize
like keeping that in mind for the
architecture because
other than kernel optimizations and such
like the last major architectural change
that we can get perf out of in puffer
would be async
I I think Lance, it's more going to be a
question of like
what is the actual degradation from one
epoch lag and like under what set of
circumstances it beneficial and can we
just get it to the point that it's like
always worth it or like never worth it
based on our experiments.
Yeah. See, so this is crazy fast but
learns nothing, right?
The obs from the end don't have to come
in in BF16.
So I guess
might not be any reason to not have them
in it.
Have to think about that.
The almost 40 mil. Oh yeah, this is
real.
Yeah, that's real.
that single GPU as well. We can get well
over um 100 mil SPS even without these
optimizations on eight GPUs.
Now, we've been at 20 for a while,
Lance, and then 20 goes to 100 on eight
GPUs.
And um we can get 40 with some
optimizations.
The 57 mil would be that would be if you
could get 16 bit compute stable.
man. I really wish that there were a
way.
I really don't like that we have to
maintain this like this macro path like
this.
It's probably several hundred lines of
bloat on its own.
This is Yeah, it is mental. This is what
I do, man.
It's pretty funny, you know, even when
people end up doing uh their own Sims
with Puffer, like they're kind of just
better off hiring us because like you
can definitely get it to work, but you
know, by the time you get your thing to
work, it'll be several times faster in
the new versions.
See you Lance.
Thanks for dropping by.
These Alex just have to stay, right?
What do we use long tensor for?
yeah, it's annoying. We kind of do have
to keep it.
We use this all over the place and this
is not tested.
There's a lot of bloat like this, but I
don't have a good solution to this at
the moment. It's just genuinely kind of
hard, right?
lots of little ops that may or may not
be optimized. We can mess with
Do these have block size on them? None
of them do, right?
I think I would prefer that we just take
all of our like obnoxious stupid
operations
like these casts for instance
and I think we'd stick them
like here, right?
Zero squeeze uns like I can do this
right.
Yeah. And this doesn't use none of this
uses like block size or anything, right?
In fact, I think
these can even go above the casts.
Probably like this.
Then we can start having um
all the other crap in here.
You see how much time it takes to slowly
clean everything up here?
takes a very long time.
Okay, we're going to have to look closer
to start finding um
jank to fix. Ignoring the names of stuff
for Now,
I don't know if my end is good enough
before I do a sweep.
Well, you can just train with defaults
and see is it if it learns anything.
Like you should be able to learn
something without sweeping. Also, sweeps
are not that expensive.
Like typically it's oh I have to go get
lunch or oh it's time to be done for the
evening or oh I have a spare GPU
Yeah, typically the best thing to do is
like you can try that on laptop. Um
like generally we just suggest people
rent a cheap GPU off of if they don't
have one.
They're like literally you can get a
better GPU for less than 10 cents an
hour most of the time.
Oh yeah, there's way too much crap in
here.
There's a lot of stupid validation,
isn't it?
Do I just want to defer this or do I
want to hack like eliminate some of it?
I don't know yet.
Let me grab myself a drink real quick.
I'll be uh I'll be right back and we'll
continue on this. Oh yeah, for anybody
who's new around here, puffer.ai, it's
all open source. Start on GitHub. Helps
us out a lot. I'll be right back.
Annoyingly, it's not really getting much
shorter, is it?
I think it will, though.
It's a little bit deceiving because or a
little bit deceptive because we have
also um we unguled a bunch of stuff
Obviously, this just shifts a few things
around, but
First thing we've actually shifted to
another file
Not a single thing that you can just
like, oh, it'll do that just fine
because it won't.
Okay. Yep. Bloated. You can kind of just
when you've been doing this for a while,
you can kind of just tell when it's just
being stupid.
cuz it'll just like if you say, "Oh
yeah, look for stuff to cut." It'll just
read line by line and just say, "Is this
line redundant? Is this line redundant?
Is this" It won't like, "Well, is this
implementing a thing that's implemented
here and like completely duping
everything for absolutely no reason?"
We're refactoring some things at the
moment.
Well, sometimes Jess, it's just like I
don't know. This could end up win. This
could end up worse. It could end up
about the same. Let's just do it and
back.
It takes forever though to do this, man.
We're only 10% of the way through this
file. Not even.
I mean, I can only reasonably go through
and mess with like 500 to a,000 lines a
day.
a couple more hours
and we're making progress at the very
least. Like this is doable. This can be
gotten into the correct shape and it can
be done in a not horrible amount of
time. I'm actually at the very least I
don't completely hate this anymore since
Grock is faster.
If you have to sit here for 10 minutes
between every little thing, it's awful
cuz then you feel like a [ __ ] for not
just doing it yourself.
I mean, as long as the thing can follow
basic instructions clearly and
consistently, I'd be happy to trade a
little bit of um intelligence on the
model for just running way faster.
I don't really want to break the
internet, Jess. I just want to be left
the [ __ ] alone and like solve some real
problems.
There's way too much noise and
bullshitting in AI.
BF16 OBS is faster.
Huh.
Wait, when you say BF-16 OBS, like
is this in the GPU end?
Because
that's saving one copy operation,
but it's not a it's not a host device.
That's just a VRAM VRAMm copy. That
shouldn't bottleneck at all.
I don't know what you mean by BF16 OBS
there.
though. I guess if you're testing this
with a 2,00 parameter network, like
We are going to end up doing BF-16 OBS
to be clear at some point relatively
soon, even in 5. But I didn't see a huge
thing on breakout.
Oh, it just wasn't loading.
That's like
default my optimized.
Yeah. Like you're going to need to start
putting together PRs or something, man,
that I can actually like have a
reasonable diff to review with the Perf
numbers. I'm happy to do that.
And again, they don't have to be formal
PRs that you expect to be merged. Like I
just need some reasonably short diff. I
can look at
DPU training is just doing everything.
You don't train an inch 16 though.
Okay, look at that. That's way nicer,
right?
But just you can't you can't run normal
training with ins
like if they're doing some weird
floating point or fixed point emulation
like
Yeah, this is insane.
We got like what? A couple hundred
lines.
So, the reason I'm just saying like
whatever here is because this is LLM
imported garbage. This like particular
150 lines. Anyways, um this was just so
we could have something that would run
and is correct. But yeah, this is
complete and utter crap. So, I don't
particularly care. Like, I have no
attachment to this structure. I'm happy
to let it just try to find something
shorter first before I actually have to
see what's going on cuz this is just
terrible. Like, I don't even know what
the hell this is. Like, my eyes are
bleeding reading this.
Everything up here so far is good
though.
But
I mean, we've been live for 3 hours for
500 lines of code review.
So, it's tough. We only get between one
and 200 lines reviewed per hour.
There's also we have somebody trying to
just do a clean CPU version of Craftex
as well at the moment.
I'm not sure that Craftex full GPU makes
sense. You are definitely free to try
it.
The one obvious difference though is
going to be um
uh you'll need a very slightly custom
encoder obviously for the CPU version
because you like the whole OBS is one
hot right like you're obviously not
going to materialize the one hots on CPU
and then transfer them to GPU.
So, we're going to allow the one hot
encoder for comparison obviously, but
other than that should be pretty
straightforward.
I have to look at your Mega Colonel
shenanigans at some point. like
I have not decided whether this makes
sense yet
just a launch file in the header.
I mean Puffer doesn't really have a a
heavy API in the first place. It takes
like 5 minutes to bind any reasonable
end to puffer.
capped out. Ow. All right. You have to
compare a reasonable number like 4096 or
8192. Maybe you can't use a million
goddamn environments cuz we can't train
with a million goddamn environments. I
don't even know how you're fitting that
in memory.
Um
if it's much lower you're essentially
the thing you're competing against right
is the GPU time that you would be
spending
running the environment versus doing it
async on CPU against the transfer time
host to device and device to host.
You got to be benchmarking the right
thing.
What do we have here? Craft decks will
be a very useful addend for us though.
We uh we're definitely going to be using
craft decks.
Craft decks classic is I think basically
just instasolved
for any reasonable definition.
I have to go look at the benchmarks, but
from what I've heard it's like
instasolved with a half decent encoder.
Like the original benchmark was just
stupid. The author like capped it to a
million steps because stupid
roof heavy.
Uh yeah, that's normal.
Yeah, that's normal to just get railed
by uh the old guard ML.
It's decent for just like intellectual
maturity, I guess, but it's like not
particularly germanine to your typical
work.
at 1 mil cannot get 306.
That has to be a tiny policy.
You can't run the forward pass. You
can't run the forward pass that fast. I
know for sure.
So, something's wrong.
Like, that doesn't even make sense with
the flops on the GPU.
Yeah, adding the policy in
is Grock Jank but faster. I don't know.
It's probably a little bit worse, but
it's much faster.
Do you have one layer or something?
Elliot,
I still don't think you can even run a
hidden 32. Is it is it like a one layer
hidden ML like a one layer linear or
something? Not mining
one mining. Okay.
So yeah, that's basically nothing then.
That's like a quarter the size of the
It's like you have a 10,000. No, you
have less than a 10,000 parameter
network then.
So okay, sure. The policy is free.
Like something more realistic would be
like 256 hidden three layers or
something maybe for crap decks.
I mean, obviously you don't have to
consider that in your PF numbers, right?
But like
the target is significantly lower.
Getting craftex at like 10 mil would be
awesome.
Like 10 mil training with a actually
usable network.
And then 10 mil, right? We scale
linearly. So, it's 80 mil on eight GPUs.
I just need to have like some
understanding of the target, right?
This one's actually a bit big cuz it has
the arrow keys on it. I like the uh the
one I have in Maryland more.
Well, thanks Grock for telling me that
the uh the code isn't cancer. There.
link cart pull.
No,
I mean there like 10 different versions
of this by now you can look at man
Yeah, I'm getting a little tired here,
but I think we can get through
what? A bit more, right? Maybe not
vectorization. I think if we just get
through this config section,
it'll be nice.
Wait, what?
Oh, no. Just online. Like a million
different people have versions of it.
right.
Getting tired. Let's just figure this
out. Um,
this table,
this is more compact, but kind of crap.
Wait.
Uh,
this is weird.
Oh, okay. This is just crap.
Uh, okay. This is just weird.
The reason this is taking me a while is
because this is just
freaking weird, man.
What the heck is with this total time
step zero?
I don't think we want to delete this cuz
this is an active use.
Rams doesn't get used here until
till later.
Yeah,
that's fine.
I'm still not fully happy with this.
Like I agree that this is actually it's
difficult to tighten, but
h you just kind of typically when it is
you just stare for longer and you figure
something out
This is way at the bottom though. We
don't need to do this right now.
me in line one of these. It's much
better.
And then we can say
that realistically the first um
600 lines been cleaned up.
Four hours of uh
refactor.
Got tired around 3 hours.
is
characters.
Doesn't really remove too many lines,
but I think with the unulfing, we're
making progress still.
I forgot we also spend a bunch of time
moving [ __ ] around. So,
we probably cleaned up um
a fair bit more.
If I just keep cleaning it up at this
pace, you know, we'll get it in in the
release target plenty. Take like a
couple weeks
to really get puffer to where it needs
to be. It's definitely worth it. In my
mind, puffer is not really worth
anything if it's not
super clean.
All right. Um,
here's what I'm going to do. First of
all, for people who are watching this
and are new, Star the Puffer on GitHub
helps out a lot. I'm kind of tired. Um,
let me see. Do I have
Let me see when I have to do stuff.
I'm use the restroom real quick and uh
then we're just going to stream a little
bit of Net Hack and chill.
I'll be right back.
Not getting in the uh the longest work
days, but we are making good consistent
progress towards 50.
All right, I'm going to switch the title
and stuff and uh we're going to play a
little bit of Net Hack since we still
have the Net Hack project. I've been
having a little bit of fun with that in
the last few days.
What's the
Oh, I can talk about that briefly, but
then I'm going to net hack here. Um,
you kind of start by you want to get the
code into roughly the right shape to
begin with.
I sort of say that as like you want all
the code to roughly be in the files that
that code should be in.
So it took me a couple days to come to
like the eight file split
and to roughly get all the code into the
files where it should go.
And uh some of those files are going to
be more of your own code. Some of those
files are going to be some like AI glue
crap.
And uh from there you kind of have to
anything that's already your own code is
basically fine. All you have to do is
put it roughly in the file where you
want it to go.
Anything that's AI crap, if it's fully
AI crap, you can first try some like
complete automated refactor. Just taste
make this shorter. Um but then once it
gets into something that's like actually
readable, you have to start actually
going through bit by bit and looking for
things.
So that's how you get it though to the
spot where you can even read it because
the thing is
the project will otherwise you can very
easily get into a state where it's not
even human readable
and in my mind that just makes stuff
have like zero value. Stuff needs to be
human readable and editable.
Right. I got to mine town yesterday.
tinninging kit.
Oh, I already Yeah, this is me. Cool.
I think I wanted that tinninging kit.
I should also
change this
Oh Jesus.
Well,
Okay. Wait. None of the equipment is
cursed.
I doubt that the leather armor is
better,
but we can just take off armored
Studded leather or banded male? I
presumably this is
banded mail is better. Right.
Wait, isn't that lower is better in
this, right?
Wearing a piece of armor subtracts its
AC. Okay, so the banded mail is better
anyways,
as expected.
Take off the studded leather.
And I doubt that the shield is going to
be better,
but we can put the large shield on.
AC4.
Uh, it's just a normal shield. Okay. So,
we want to take off
and we want to wear
the cloak.
Why am I AC3?
I'm not wearing armor.
A
Okay,
we want to wear
Okay.
AC negative3. Lovely.
And in the meantime, my cat has
genocided everything.
Okay,
we can take
Oops.
How are we burdened with this? Oh,
bugle.
This thing heavy
maybe.
I can't move diagonal for some reason
here
If I die because of this, this is very
stupid,
but I don't think I will.
Okay.
Hey Ryan
going up for net hack.
Did I miss Soabon?
Isn't it uh like mine town or soabon
later?
I thought there was a branching.
Oh, it's in the mazes. Okay,
I think we're fine.
Can I
on if this is Is there a general store?
This is a general store, isn't it?
Wait, hang on.
No, this is a general store, right?
So, I should just be able to drop
scrolls.
Oh, for wait for scrolls
for both of them.
Why is it asking me to? That's
ridiculous.
How do we do
we bless a scroll?
No.
I mean, I can just read it,
but I kind of want to figure out how we
just identify all of our scrolls.
No. How do we get holy water?
And can you even use that on uh
Okay, I don't have an altar at the
moment.
So,
let's name
item
Okay,
we be lazy. That's all we're going to
need to do for now.
We could drop the gems. Do we care about
our gems or do we just get rid of them?
Identified gems.
So they'll just I see. So you need to
know what they are.
Okay. The only other thing I know I can
do here,
Get my pet to attack him.
Doesn't look like it.
You don't have anything to eat.
Uh, really? That's a problem, isn't it?
Top metal shop has
Yeah, I have to sell some stuff so I can
buy food then.
Oh, I'm blind,
right?
Will general store buy armor?
Uh yeah, definitely research. Let's just
call it research. That'll be good.
Great.
That's annoying.
Well, I got to pick everything back up.
Thanks, Kvert.
Um, so I basically almost just died by
stupidly eating
old corpse and getting food poisoning.
Uh, I saved myself through prayer.
So, let's hope I don't need to do that
for a while.
Now I have a tin of iron piercer.
I don't know if this thing has limited
uses,
but for now I am fine.
Why is my cat just like doing this?
There he goes. Get back here. Stupid.
Um, how do I light?
Can I light a candle?
Apply command.
So we just apply
Oh, I forgot my
stupid cat.
Now is this. This is tame large cat.
That is a kitten.
Okay.
Then leave a corpse.
experience level six. Lovely.
So hopefully we find some corpses. I do
have a tinning kit.
We should be fine for a little bit as
long as I don't just get stalled.
And I find a couple things to fight.
Do still have one spare tin.
What is this
lizard?
Want to get to this before my cat does
see.
Okay, I got a 10,
a sprig of wolf spain,
cures lyanthropy.
Oh,
that's useful.
Wait, why am I confu
confused?
Conf.
Why am I just randomly confused and
stunned?
so
I have no idea why that happened, but
it's probably from the thing from
before.
Okay.
We are fine.
I just don't need any more of the uh
random stuff.
Say we have a hole,
an angled pole axe.
I think we're just going to make a a
beline
for this. Cuz
I need food,
I guess. Candle burnt out.
That's bad.
This is probably from the poisoning
before.
This might unfortunately just be delayed
death.
We will see.
Okay, I'm getting hungry every like side
steps.
No, tripe is
poison, right?
Apply a tinning kit.
And then
we wield
dagger.
Then we eat
10.
Tinning kit makes it safe.
I don't understand why I'm still hungry.
I keep eating and eating, but it's still
hungry.
Okay.
Attending cat
eat.
Oh [ __ ] Idiot.
That was cannibalism. Whoops.
Uh,
I don't understand why I'm hungry every
three steps.
did that just happen without me
noticing?
God damn it. Stupid cat ate ate the
food.
build. See
apply.
Okay. Why am I just constantly hungry? I
don't understand.
We need to figure this out or it's just
going to end the run.
I wearing anything else? It's like
weird.
This thing
giant beetle.
Yeah, I probably still have the luck
penalty as well.
I honestly, this is just one of those
things where I just have no idea what
the hell happened. Like, I just started
burning food at 10 times the normal pace
and I have no idea why.
Well, this is a winter wolf cub
that will wreck me at the moment.
So, we just kind of run a little bit,
huh?
I honestly don't know what's happening
this game though.
It was like fine and and
poisonous.
Okay, we can we can t this
That's why I was doing no damage. Didn't
have my spear.
Peaceful.
Peaceful gnome king
owl bear and a blindfold.
Okay, we're fine.
We are 100% fine.
All right,
we have food.
We can now afford to kind of just chill
out a little bit.
Peaceful dwarf is following me because
No reason.
Warish Maddock.
It would be a nice digging tool to have.
just explore. Nope. Do we just explore
very small amount perhaps
Okay.
By the time we get back, I should have
some reasonable health.
Oh,
great.
I thought it was safe if you tended
Let's
I thought just tinning stuff made it
safe. It does not.
Yeah.
Hey, just Okay, it's still tame.
Let's just wait out this stun.
I don't get it, man.
700 nutrition.
Uh, you can't see it, but there is. But
mine is going at 10 times the normal
Hey,
Okay, I can t it.
You can eat the tin.
Let's apply
handle
And you're not full. It's constant
hunger. It's very weird.
A trap door opens under you.
forest center.
And I'm hungry again, man.
I don't get it. I This is just going to
kill me. And I have no idea why.
I've eaten like 20 food.
I don't understand.
Poor centaur
rape.
Is there anything else cursed? It could
be
a jeweled wand.
Interesting.
All right. Well, we have food for a
while.
It's very weird when it's just like I
just have no idea why something is
happening and I can't find information
on it.
Which I guess that's kind of how it
feels to play a net hack as an RL agent
as well.
Um, eat something.
Let's eat the
Yeti meat.
That's fine.
What are these?
Soldier ant.
Come here, cat.
I can uh
mess with. Oh, it could also just be I'm
carrying a ton of stuff, right?
Oh, well, we'll see how this goes.
Throw.
Oops.
Let's throw some darts.
rank takes turn?
Do I try it again?
I'm dead. Cool. I don't know what the
hell, man. The hunger thing totally
screwed me up.
Uncursed amulet ESP. That's where I got
that from. That makes sense.
Uncursed ring of teleport control. I
should have known that from before. That
wasn't what was screwing me.
warded.
Unlucky.
Well, I know where that came from.
I don't understand the hunger thing.
I just want to understand that right
now.
My best run.
And I actually have no idea what the
heck it was that screwed that up.
Is nutrition is it affected by weight or
something?
All right. Very weird. I actually have
no idea what the heck, but that was um
the soldier ant was whatever. It was
pretty much just the um
the like 10x hunger drain. I have no
idea why that happened.
See if I can figure that out. Anyways,
thanks for tuning in, folks. I'm going
to get some dinner and uh I'll probably
be back tomorrow refactoring